[Music]
you know I must have a death wish the
idea I'm going to discuss the nature of
time with one of our leading physicists
and you know in the world clearly I must
be either fearless or mad
we do know a lot more about time then
maybe some of the philosophers might
argue we do
in physics and nothing in philosophy
which chooses but which can choose
between them
xeno is trying to say it's not that time
doesn't exist for that humans haven't
yet learned how to articulate it in a
way that makes it possible
xeno was an idiot we can say a lot more
about what time really is we need to
rescue time from the jaws of physics if
we're going to see it aright
how should we make sense of time is it a
dimension a flow a place a process a
social construct or something altogether
more mysterious that's a heck of a
kickoff question they can spend the
whole hour on that one we're gonna hear
first from Jim al-khalili a professor of
theoretical physics at the University of
Surrey presenter of radio force finest
science program at nine and a paradox
which he manages to tweet about on an
almost hourly basis for many people the
common-sense view is that we don't know
what time is and the common-sense view
is is actually what goes back to Isaac
Newton
and for many people who haven't taken a
course on relativity theory we think we
haven't progressed from there so there's
this cosmic clock that ticks by the
seconds the minutes the hours at the
same rate for every one and although we
have our own subjective view of time
that if if you're enjoying this hour
it'll go by very quickly if you're bored
you know the time will will drag but you
know that so the ways on the former
focus on the former absolutely there's
no danger but we know that's our own
subjective view of time actually in 1905
Einstein published his special theory of
relativity where he showed that that
view of time is wrong time isn't an
absolute it's not something abstract
something that we had invented or
something that we have no control over
time is more tangible than that it's
tangible on this in the way that space
is tangible now in space we know we we
have access to three dimensions of space
and we can move forwards and backwards
up and down left and right in time we
are constrained to moving in one
direction so we thinking in certainly in
physics as time as having an arrow a
direction I remember one of my finest
moments was when I was doing my PhD and
I was looking up some papers in the
university library and I came across one
even Hawking's papers mid-80s and when
he talks about the arrows of time the
direction of time and how can you define
the direction of time is past and future
just something we've invented and
actually in his paper there are several
definitions of time and and he then goes
on to point out that one way of defining
time is in the direction in which the
universe is expanding so the past forget
human memory what if humans had never
evolved what if there was no life than
the universe would there still be time
yes of course there will be time it's
part of the fabric of what the universe
is space-time as as Einstein calls it
and so Hawking said well if we define
the direction of timers for going from
the Big Bang onwards so the Big Bang
smaller universe is in the past
the direction of time is the direction
of the expansion of the universe but if
our psychological error of time the way
we think of part remembering the past
and looking to the future is in the same
direction as that how would we know if
the universe is actually contracting
maybe the universe is getting smaller
that's because our arrow of time is
always pointing the direction of
expansion of time and the first two or
three pages of this paper I followed and
then he got into the mass and Stephen
Hawking's math wasn't the same as my
math seal it depends on what area of
physics you're in and I lost him there
but I was aware that he'd made a mistake
about the error of time and I remember
making some notes and then remember a
few years later reading brief history of
time where he conceded he'd made a
mistake and remember reading this on the
train and smiley grinning to myself that
I proved somehow the Stephen Hawking it
made made a mistake but but it points to
the fact that even modern physics
doesn't really understand quite how time
fits into to our theories of the
universe relativity theory tells us that
time can be squeezed and stretched
there's no absolute time time depends on
the observer if two people are traveling
at high speed relative to each other
close to the speed of light they will
measure time at flowing at different
rates they will see each other's clocks
running slower there is no absolute
present now it depends on your frame of
reference
and yet the other great theory of modern
physics quantum mechanics doesn't really
describe time in in this more complete
way in quantum mechanics time is just
what's called a parameter it's just a
way of ensuring how things change
cranking the handle from past to future
and and one of the big questions in
modern physics is how do we reconcile
Einstein's general relativity with
quantum mechanics because until then we
won't have a correct theory of time but
we do know a lot more about time then
maybe some of the philosophers might
argue we do it is much more than
psychological time it's much more than
just how we care to define it there's an
absolute necessity according to Einstein
that exists whether or not humans care
to pontificate and philosophize about it
Jim thank you very much for your brief
history of Hawking's brief theory we all
love when we find Hawking's ok next we
come to Ray Tallis physician philosopher
poet novelist bon river fashion icon
monkey Michelangelo's finger and the
kingdom of infinite space but for the
next hour he is bounded in this nuts
hell oh yes lovely you know I must have
a death wish the idea I'm going to
discuss the nature of time with one of
our leading physicists and you know in
the world clearly I must be either
fearless or mad but anyway I got to
disagree with Jim as well so it
indicates that I'm probably mad as well
as fearless
the truth is I don't know what time is
but I know what it isn't and I know what
it doesn't and I want to spend my four
minutes focusing on the happiness
metaphor of the arrow of time and to
argue that it's about time that x arrow
was put back into its quiver I think
it's a helpful and metaphor and it's
based on a deep rooted and revealing
misunderstanding of the nature of time
the arrow of time metaphor coined by
Arthur Eddington by the way very great
astronomist astrophysicist is a response
to the notion that time has a direction
the idea that it flows or moves in a
certain way and particularly that it
moves forwards rather than sideways or
backwards and this notion is reinforced
I think by the way in science we
represent moments as occupying locations
in a dimension a dimension usually
marked T so that time will seem when
it's represented like a growing line and
this license is a variety of daft
questions one of which that Jim referred
to and an age put decide for example how
fast is time moving what is it growing
into and how fast is it growing and we
both of us would agree that is a for all
sorts of reasons a non question now of
course representing time as a line
that's growing is a very useful way of
representing the unfolding of events in
physics as witness its value in in in
other science we've all benefited from
over the last in the post Galilean era
and the science to which people like Jim
have contributed enormously but I think
it's important not to muddle this way of
representing time with time itself
for a start it tempts us to think of
time as analogous to space hence all
that stuff about time travel all of
which is uniform nonsense making time a
dimension doesn't of course necessarily
spatialize it and many physicists would
deny that we are specializing time by
making it a dimension and off on all
fours with the three dimensions of space
but it does render time vulnerable to be
conceived spatially venerable to
spaceflight metaphors such as the arrow
of time because after all poor old time
is only one dimension but there are
three dimensions of space so it's
outnumbered it arrives if you like
d'artagnan I think adding on to the
three musketeers so it's really got to
you know follow the party line despite
these problems there have been efforts
to give the notion of the arrow of time
a scientific respectability and there
was two outward to see what in physical
terms would underpin the notion the time
has a direction and that's why trying to
find irreversible processes in the
universe and this is a bit awkward
because most of the basic laws of the
universe are time reversible there's no
reason why I think should go one way one
another
can we please thank our extremely well
tempered
[Applause]
[Music]